the Queen's death certificate was
released a little earlier on by the
national records of Scotland it lists
her death as occurring at 10 past three
in the afternoon at Balmoral Castle he
says that the cause of death was old age
the certificate itself signed by Anne
her daughter the Princess Royal and we
also have information there regarding
the usual residence it says Windsor
Castle here which today finally reopened
its doors to visitors and from early
this morning they were queuing up
outside to have their chance to enter
the castle and of course go into Saint
George's Chapel where the queen was laid
to rest 10 days ago inside the King
George VI Memorial Chapel and walking
inside it was a very quiet somber
atmosphere one woman turned to me and
said I didn't expect to feel this move
did all all just feels and looks so
final now doesn't it and in fact
interestingly at the front of the cube
to women who had been at the front of
the queue for the lying in state as well
and they both agreed it was another
moment they didn't want to miss as the
country said goodbye to the queen to the
Monarch and they came out and said to me
it was just so sad being inside the
chapel itself is very small they said It
felt intimate it felt private there were
beautiful flowers around the stone
that's now being laid and they came out
visibly moved does have many people here
as well as Windsor really reopens again